we've all heard the word unprecedented a
lot this week about the fbi raid on
former president trump's residence at
mar-a-lago
and well yeah that's correct it doesn't
fully convey just how outside the norm
this operation was
for that discussion we thought would
bring in two guests with unique
perspectives on this entire affair craig
shirley presidential historian and
ronald reagan biographer and monica
crowley former treasury assistant
secretary under trump who also served as
president nixon's foreign policy
assistant during his final year she's
the only person i think to work for both
men monica let's start with you
you say that the date of the raid
has some significance explain
yeah lori you know when it comes to the
deep state and how they operate there
are no coincidences so the date that
they chose to raid president trump's
personal residence was august 8 2022
august 8 1974 was the date that
president nixon announced his
resignation so this was a message event
perhaps more than anything on the part
of the fbi and dealing with president
trump this week and the message was
anyone who challenges the regime's
corrupt power will be destroyed in many
ways president nixon was the first
modern president to be a casualty of the
deep state and president trump's enemies
and their institutional enemies whether
it's the deep state the media the
international community the left and so
on those enemies were nixon's enemies
this is not to excuse president nixon's
behavior during watergate laura but it
is a way of setting all of this into
context these are the same enemies and
both presidents nixon and trump flew a
little too close to the sun for the
regime's taste and they felt that their
power was threatened their absolute
power and their absolute grip on the
country was threatened by these two
presidents and therefore they both
needed to be destroyed
now craig you have a view on
the way this unfolded
and how it will impact joe biden's
entire legacy
explain that for us
joe biden's legacy is going to be
entirely
one of corruption
there's nothing redeeming so far about
his presidency i don't anticipate
anything you redeem me about his
presidency whatsoever
there's nothing uh to write home about
about this presidency is that one thing
i think that this probably guarantees uh
trump's certain nomination probably
re-election in 2024 and and biden's uh
defeat in uh in 2024.
well monica listen to what uh speaking
of nixon john dean had to say this week
they had to take an extraordinary action
to protect the national security
documents and that's appears what this
is the nara the national archives is
very aggressive with this sort of thing
this has been in months in development
you've got an agency that's very
protective of its documents and wants
them who would have thought that we'd
have a president that is more
troublesome than richard nixon i never
dreamed that someone would make him look
like a choir boy but here we are
and we've got he uh he looks awfully
good today as opposed to the problems we
got with trump
monica he's been dining out on watergate
for i don't know 50 years now
but your reaction to that little fossil
coming out
well a little revisionist history coming
from john dean isn't that very rich
laura i mean it's just it's incredible
look the left including john dean will
always find a brand new villain whether
it was george w bush or ronald reagan
and now it's donald trump they always
have that villain in their crosshairs no
matter what but now they realize that
like president nixon donald trump
represents an existential threat to
their absolute grip on the country and
their absolute power and so he's got to
be destroyed and that's why they
continue over the last six years and
ongoing laura to try to take president
trump out they have thrown the kitchen
sink at this man and the fact that he is
still standing is a miracle it's also a
testament to his character both
political and personal that he has
survived all of this i don't know
another leader never mind another human
being who could have withstood the
pressures and the attacks that donald
trump has withstood but he also
represents a future threat because he is
likely to be the republican nominee
should he seek to to uh pursue that and
could be the next president as well in
which case their power will be even more
threatened so in many ways president
trump is an even more threat as an
outsider than richard nixon ever was now
craig earlier this week
this presidential historian michael
beschloss offered
some interesting analysis of this raid
watch we hear a lot of people saying we
have never seen before in history the
household of a president of the united
states being searched by the fbi
and that is true but we must never say
that without also including the last
half of the sentence which is we've
never seen a president behave like
donald trump with his contempt and a
difference to the law
now craig is that
usually historians take
events as they're happening
yeah no laura's not look all presidents
are unique all presidents are different
uh
my the last question you asked me i
didn't answer the question very well but
let me try now is that i i reread the
the declaration uh of independence today
it's astonishing how many of the
corruptions of the british government
are being revisited by this new threat
to american democracy and society i feel
like a lot of us are like tom payne
at the cusp of the american revolution
when he wrote these are the times that
try men's souls and that that tyranny
like hell is not is uh not easily
conquered uh joe biden
uh is not going to be easily conquered
but in his corruption it
we must take control of congress to
bring sanity back to washington uh once
and for all well in control of congress
with actual action
it's not enough to take control of
congress and sit on your hands and like
let's play patty cake with the same
people want to destroy the country so i
well i'm done with that i know you are
totally crazy i'm with you some of these
republican leaders remind me of uh what
uh
john what gene mccarthy once told me he
said they reminded him of
somebody who went on the battlefield and
shot his own wounded uh and we've got
republican leadership that is just like
that and they need to be they maybe got
rid of i
need we need a good house cleaning not
just the democrats but it's
establishmentarian republicans
it's time for them to move on down the
road monica craig great to see both of
you thank you for your perspectives
tonight hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else